on friday followers of powerful shia
cleric mukhtar
al-sadr took over baghdad's tahrir
square
in the imam's words the goal of this
friday prayer was to defend their
religion and homeland
in the face of immorality and
non-believers
a criticism of the secular leaning
anti-establishment protesters
who until recently occupied this
the square protests had positive and
negative sides
as for the negative sides of these
protests the hands of the american
occupiers spread the obscenity in tahrir
square
the prayers also aimed to shore up
political support
[Applause]
yes yes to our leader they proclaimed
their support for sutter
after he announced his aim to secure a
majority in the forthcoming
parliamentary elections
which would allow him to nominate the
prime minister
leader for all iraqis the sunnis the
shia and the kurds
he is considered a shepherd for all
iraqis he will not run for himself
but for these people his constituents he
represents
all iraqis but many disagree the prayer
took place in the same square where just
weeks ago
security forces cleared remnants of
iraq's beleaguered protest movement
which had aimed to topple the ruling
class including the soddrists
who won the last elections activists say
the protests gradually lost steam due to
violence
and because political parties including
the sudhirists
hijacked their cause they infiltrate the
demonstrators
the demonstrations squares in baghdad
and in every city wherever they can and
they try
to manipulate the process and try to get
use of it
sutter has long tried to brand himself a
reformist
and initially supported the protests but
in the end
he is seen as having chosen to protect
the system
they have lost a lot of grounds
political grounds social grounds
people who have doubted them as being
real uh
reform assists but they found out they
are not they are just part of the
political regime which runs the country
since 2003
so they are now trying to gain back some
of the grounds
and indeed thousands turned out to show
their loyalty for sutter
friday's prayer was a display of power
on the part of the southwest movement
ahead
of the june elections but
anti-government protesters have
struggled to organize politically
to put up a serious challenge to
incumbent parties like the soldiers
further aiding their prospects for
electoral success
simona faulting al jazeera baghdad